what's the purpose of a character's
death in a story
good question what is the character's
death what does that do for the story
what is the purpose of that well death
magnifies death
elevates a story
and I would say
in your cast of characters
death should be one of the characters
who comes around who threatens
um
or who actually steps on stage and Deals
out death to someone you know like the
figure of death with the scythe and the
hood
that we see in cartoons all the time
um
yeah that uh is an important and I think
even mandatory element to have in a
story and I don't mean that literally
necessarily although it's great if it's
there as a threat or an actuality
um
but the possibility of death or failure
is the metaphorical way to look at it
that it's the death of the possible
death of your hopes the possible death
of your dreams
um that's I think operative in that Cary
Grant's notorious example that he's
hoping for his belief in love to be
restored but he's really dubious about
it because death got in the way in the
past and death is threatening now so
there's a tension between those forces
but the death of a character
um
maybe the thing that makes it into a
worthy story that the hero either dies
or experiences death quite nearby
someone near and dear to them dies or
they are forced to deal death to someone
else that's a traumatic thing that
sometimes can be quite a powerful
movement in a story and maybe they feel
responsible or they uh
uh blame themselves
but the death helps to elevate the story
and and is almost a necessity in order
to really uh shake the audience and and
communicate with them that this is quite
a serious it is a matter of life and
death
should death serve the plot or the
themes or both
well yes death should serve
um
both the plot and the themes it kind of
uh works almost in a mechanical way
within the plot
but we haven't talked about themes much
but the theme I think there should be
one overriding theme in most stories
there can be multiple ideas but one
basic human quality that you're
exploring and death should definitely
lean over that and cast a shadow on
whatever that human quality is if you're
talking about uh Brotherhood or loyalty
or friendship or trusts
um that should be threatened
and you know that would be your theme is
I'm going to talk today about ambition
well what if your ambition is thwarted
by uh death or failure uh that would add
gravity to the story and maybe shine
some light on uh on the theme by testing
it severely to the point of death
so those things can all work together to
make it a nice design what impact does
the death of the hero have on other
characters in the story oh that's a
great thing when the hero dies or
appears to die there is an impact on
everybody else in the story uh the great
example that brought this to my
attention as a young film student when I
was looking for the hidden rules and had
just found them in the work of Joseph
Campbell so there's the whole pattern
then I went to see the first Star Wars
movie which came out within a few days
after reading Campbell for the first
time and by golly there everything was
but in the critical scene in the middle
of that movie that corresponds from me
to the ordeal stage eight in my frame
um is that they're in this giant trash
Masher thing at the bottom of the Death
Star and Luke Skywalker our hero is
Pulled Under by something with tentacles
and appears to uh have died not for long
but for just a few frames you see
bubbles come up and then no bubbles the
water goes flat and then the attention
turns away from him to all the other
characters who are watching and they are
freaking out because they think the
evidence is telling them Master Luke is
dead he's been pulled to his death and
so they're all thinking how am I going
to go on and who's going to be the hero
now and I sitting in the audience am one
with them wondering
if I'm not Luke Skywalker anymore who am
I in this movie I identified with him
I'm going through the story wanting what
he wants and now if he's dead
who am I so there was this sense of
unease and uh a sense that something's
been pulled out of the design and it
creates a vacuum and I think that's uh
embedded in
um a lot of ancient rituals
uh that go back to the Stone Age times
when to escape from the ice sheets from
the glaciers we had to go into caves in
Europe they acted out these kind of
scenes where uh the shaman or the leader
of the ceremony would take on the Robes
of a buffalo or something and would
dance around and then would seem to die
it's it's like built in it's like baked
into
ritual
performances that uh you will enact the
life of the characters of of these
Supernatural forces like the Buffalo
Spirit or something like that but also
their death
and the audience
um is programmed or trained to react by
Crying by you know holding themselves
tight and worrying oh what's going to
happen to us now that we don't have a
hero to protect us they gather around
the sort of pit where the hero has
fallen in and are deeply affected by it
and depressed
and this is part of the magic of the
hero's journey is that then that figure
the robed uh Shaman who's playing the
role of the Buffalo or Luke Skywalker
comes back to life
sort of defying our expectations and our
understanding of death is permanent so
if someone appears to die they're dead
and then they come back again wow we get
a supernatural Boost from that it gives
us a lift and this is sort of the inner
mechanism of uh all stories I think and
all religious rituals and all kind of
performances of of any kind
is to take you to that edge let you
experience that for a few moments and
then bring life back into the picture
and it transforms you it you don't come
back to the same level
it's like if you took a basketball and
pushed it down under the water
um
it's
resisting you it wants to come back up
to the surface and if you just suddenly
let go of it it doesn't just Bob up to
the surface it actually flies up out of
the water
so the same thing is happening with
human emotions that when you depress
them by apparently killing the hero by
making me think the hero has died
the audience's emotions are temporarily
depressed and they'll go along with it
even though they know I've seen the
movie before and I know Luke Skywalker
doesn't die here he's going to live but
just for that second part of you on this
cave person level
experiences it as if it were real
and feels all the things that you would
feel if someone dear to you had died
so then they're brought back to life and
there's this huge rush
and there's a lift and this can be done
a number of times in the course of a
story should be I think somewhere in the
middle and then certainly just before
the end we replay this at stage eight
and Stage 11
where the hero is resurrected and uh you
know the art of the Storyteller and the
filmmaker is to make the death as
convincing as possible or to make the
failure as convincing as possible
and then
turn it so that the hero wins and we get
so much more satisfaction out of that
than we would if the hero just did the
things in one uh if they did the things
and fell into a pit and almost died or
seemed to die to all appearances they've
died and then they crawl out alive
that's a tremendously more powerful
experience than just you know doing some
task and succeeding so I I think the
death
serves to involve the audience because
they're all you know existentially
concerned about their own death so
anytime you show me one on on screen uh
part of me is studying that quite
closely to see what's it going to be
like for me and maybe there's hope that
I can live through it and live again is
there such a thing as a hero's death or
a villain's death
yeah there's there is uh uh room for the
hero's death uh and for the villain's
death
um in these designs uh this is uh
something you can trace this back all
the way to the beginnings of
Storytelling if you want to go back in
let's say Anglo-Saxon literature you can
look at Beowulf Beowulf was this great
uh warrior hero who fought Monsters uh
he fought one Monster uh
battled with this thing tore its arm off
and then had to fight its mother who
came to get revenge
and then defeated that one and lived a
long time
ruling over his people and having
prosperity and good times but in the end
had to face one more Monster and there
comes a dragon
that is uh it's a terrific battle but in
the end they both go down in flames and
so the hero dies in sacrifice and that's
a common way for uh the death of a hero
to be experienced it can be experienced
tragically uh there's certainly lots of
room for that in many many stories that
end with the tragic death of the hero
and maybe it's meaningless and that
itself is a sad thing that you died for
nothing
but there are other cases where the
hero's sacrifice is Meaningful and it
was done to save others
or to show some way that maybe I
couldn't make it but you can this is
kind of the idea in the Bible where
Moses gets to the edge of the promised
land and he's within sight of it but
he's just too old and so he says you go
on to the promised land and I'm just
gonna camp out here and watch you all go
and I'll wave goodbye and we know he he
dies soon after
so uh the hero sometimes is handing it
off and uh leaving it for others to
finish and that's a noble death when the
hero sacrifices something or gives it
over to the Next Generation
as for the villains the villain's death
is a different kind of satisfaction
there is a thing called Poetic Justice
which means that whatever the hero or
the villain did they should be rewarded
or punished in a way that matches
poetically to what they did so if the
hero did something dangerous and
wonderful to save the world they should
be rewarded with love with
the crown you know with being King with
some kind of prize
some kind of Victory and if they have
failed if they have broken the rules of
the gods or have let themselves down and
let the others down then it's a tragic
kind of thing but for the villains there
should be this poetic justice so that
whatever evil thing they did to the hero
the same should be done to them a
beautiful example of this is in The
Wizard of Oz where Dorothy deals with
this wicked witch who's already set her
straw man friend on fire
and is threatening to kill her and her
dog and everybody in the team
and uh Dorothy does an act of Mercy she
takes a bucket of water and throws it on
the wit on on the Scarecrow and puts out
that fire but some of the water goes on
and splashes the Witch and Dorothy
doesn't know this but the witch is in
the book she's it says she's made of
sugar and that she just dissolves and
goes down into the floor crying out you
know my wonderful wickedness is is over
and uh so the villain's death gives us a
satisfaction that it sort of corrects
the imbalance the villain represents an
imbalance in society and the hero is
trying to bring things back to a state
of balance to a state of justice and so
it might be necessary to uh
punish the villain in accordance with
what they did it's very unsatisfying if
they get away with something and don't
have to pay an appropriate price for
what they did
audiences on some level just
instinctively know that's not a happy or
satisfying ending